emma 17 ans miss indre et loire 2015
c'est la plus jeune candidate de
l'élection miss ronde france 2016
pas évident de se présenter un tel
concours car la vie d'une jeune femme
ronde n'est pas un long fleuve
tranquille en primaire j'en ai beaucoup
souffert après arrivée au collège 6e 5e
les rondeurs c'était là tu es grosse
quoi
sans aura jamais autant bien au courant
elle à 26 ans elle est la deuxième
dauphine indre-et-loire 2015 pour elle
aussi
la société n'est pas tendre avec les
rôles des paroles un regard ça peut
vraiment blessé une personne
et je trouve ça vraiment dommage de plus
en plus présent sur le devant de la
scène les mannequins grande taille
un speed s'émousse devenu tout ça
vraiment très très bien déjà chaud qu
elles ont confiance en elle donc
forcément elles sont belles je trouve
que quand on a confiance en soi ça donne
tout de suite la beauté et je trouve
qu'ils ont beaucoup de courage elles
sont vraiment très très belle en plus
elle se met dans n'importe quelle tenue
souvent dans le magazine on les vend à
promouvoir les maillots de bain et
choquent elles sont magnifiques et je
pense que c'est vraiment des mannequins
il en faudrait encore plus d'ailleurs
thierry frézard à créer ce concours il y
a huit ans une preuve d'amour pour sa
femme auront le secret d'état belge
avait 80% fx sont inscrits à miss ronde
en sont vraiment très contente
elles ont vraiment avancer un maximum de
l'acceptation de soi
au passe aux choses sérieuses tenue de
ville
cosplay chorégraphies des anciennes miss
passage en mado tenue de gala c'est tout
comme miss france peut être en plus
convivial solidaire et bon enfant
un discours également pour convaincre on
s'y croirait et finalement c'est aurore
qui emporte les diadèmes très ému je m'y
attendais pas je suis très fier de ce
que j'ai fait du parcours que j'ai pu
faire aussi
et comme quoi le travail porte ses
fruits que voilà quand on a la volonté
on peut y arriver
pas de déception pour emma et sa soeur
arrivées respectivement deuxième et
première dauphine où la finale nationale
aura lieu en janvier prochain
38 secoueront dom tom et pom pom